[Music]
these days the world is full of
different takes on the news we get
reporters takes and pundits takes and
politicians takes and random people on
social media's takes
but there's one important take that's
missing your mom's tape
so we'd like to bring that to you now in
a segment called
your mom's take
that's right we brought your mom into
our studio
hey sweetheart hey stand up straight
yes ma'am so i'm going to read some
recent headlines and after each one your
mom is going to give us
her take on it you're welcome here we go
man captured wearing company lanyard
during u.s capital riots fired
by employer you play stupid games you
win stupid prizes
that's right ohio state cancels football
game against illinois amid virus
outbreak
i am tired of virus outbreaks you know
what we need
an outbreak of manners please and thank
you
oh my baby i remember mama oh
kamala harris receives coronavirus
vaccination
oh she has time to get the vaccine but
she doesn't have time to call me back
okay she's very busy mom is he doing
what i'm busy
okay kim aang makes major league
baseball history as first female general
manager
that could have been you if you applied
yourself mom i don't know anything about
baseball
and i'm not a woman did you hear
something
no i did i heard a bunch of excuses
okay a japanese startup is building
wooden satellites
oh those are cute i'm gonna buy two and
use them as end tables
they're satellites that cost millions of
dollars i'm worth it
yes you are mom oh my baby
[Music]
george clooney makes surprising grooming
confession
the surprise is that a man is grooming
do you get it yeah yeah you can use that
in your little comedy show if you want
to
we'll throw it in i can help okay
the u.s divorce rate is the lowest it's
been in 50 years
well it's gonna go up again if your
father doesn't start picking up after
himself
i'm just kidding i'm not gonna divorce
your father okay
today what mom keep going
and finally owner reopens jim despite
shut down orders i hope he's opening a
morgue
too this has been your mom's take
i told you to stand up straight i am
don't you talk back to me
[Music]
you